came up with this idea it's so dry on
the outside like it's like absolutely
taste it goes all your saliva goes away
no see you same both and you're watching
snack wars for sport Bible so this is
roots and I'm sure it's not gonna taste
good this is the thing that we drink
when we say I'll get you're trying to
get strong so it's not something we
drink every day maybe we should not be
forced to drink that now this easy why
this happens like oh my god open this
can like right there fighting this stuff
in my best friend eat trying to be
healthy and everything that macro who's
the better man yeah I know this taste I
don't like this yeah I remember these
you guys are bringing back a lot of
memories this is coconut biscuits or
cookies but back in the days they were
nice and sweet and soft
but all the memories one just a pie like
a medium pie
a big one
it was not a pie it looks like a closet
in foil and everything kind of looks
good though
I must say I'm not sort of feel but
tastes good on the inside but the
outside is that dry dry came up with
this idea it's so dry on the outside
like it's like absolutely taste it goes
all your saliva goes away yeah banana
chips everybody's in Jamaica love these
old young newborn I'm taking these by
the way these are potato chips salt and
vinegar you can tell got vinegar in it
Malaga actually hit the sauce up but
wouldn't vinegar that bit is Martin it's
a good son so I'm guessing these are the
soreness I remember this grown-ups I
don't think it has no chance I think I
drank a lot of this going up looking
you're really younger you can afford it
so yeah I like medium balls made some
good stuff
let's see no not even close
oh that wasn't even close
come on janeshia hit im Usain Bolt and
that was snack or a sport
[Music]